what's up guys my name is the channel
welcome back to another hazel
devlog so today we're gonna be talking
about skeletal animation a feature that
has actually been in hazel for quite
some time but due to me kind of not
maintaining it and just kind of
slapping it in like a year ago and then
you know most of the engine changing i
guess it kind of fell behind got covered
in dust you know no one used it for ages
and i had to go back and fix it but now
it's back and it's
better than ever so i thought i would
give you guys a quick little update to
show you skeletal animation working and
what that looks like
because i promised i would make more of
these devlog update videos one other
thing that i want to quickly mention is
i know a lot of you were interested in
shadows don't worry we're not gonna
completely gloss over that i am gonna
dive deeper into shadows probably next
week
show you guys a little bit more about
how they actually work and various cool
little optimization strategies
and and all the different layers of them
as well so don't worry we are going to
go back to those features and in fact
we'll probably start covering a lot of
hazel devs actual features
in more depth rather than being like hey
guys look i just i have this now
surprise
um because obviously that's going to be
a lot more useful to you guys and just
seeing
seeing cool stuff which which is fun but
you know anyway i promise this would be
a quick little update so we're just
going to dive in and take a look at
skeletal animation
okay so here is the little test scene
that i put together
during the live stream i'll have both of
these models linked down in the
description below by the way these were
both models just suggested to me by
stream chat
literally clicked on them they're both
on sketchfab just downloaded them and
put them into hazel and i'll show you
what that workflow looks like in a
minute as well it's all really simple
because it really is simple as in i
haven't fleshed out the workflow inside
hazel just yet this is all kind of still
pretty early stuff now animation has
been here inside hazel for a
pretty long time like this gun for
example um has
i think probably almost a year old in
terms of
i remember showing it back in the day
probably like last year inside hazeldev
so it's nothing really new but i have um
obviously uh refined it quite a bit i've
also as you can see
made it work with the shadows so you can
see um
the shadows showing up over here on the
cube is a good example and on the floor
obviously and
everything looks pretty good so yeah i
don't know if there's anything really
else to say this is what
what animation looks like um okay so how
do we get it in here so let's go ahead
and delete
the storm trooper so i've selected this
the stormtrooper uh
should we go to the pilot now let's get
rid of the stormtrooper so i'll get rid
of the swarm trooper just by deleting
him
now i'm going to go ahead and create a
new mesh under mesh
i'm just going to hit this button here
we will go ahead and navigate to the
right directory
and then i'll get this silly dancing fbx
file of course the download link for
this will be
in the description below we'll import it
now here he is looks like he's like in
the center of the screen here
let's go ahead and drag him out here now
it doesn't import with
textures for some reason i think this is
just due to the path
not being there i'm not sure what it
expects for the path
so it's trying to load the
yeah it's trying to load it from like
either within the fbx or within like
some i'm not sure what it's doing there
but anyway if you find that a model like
this that has textures clearly
in it so for example this model here so
this stormtrooper for example comes with
you know this albedo texture it doesn't
have any other textures like normals or
anything like that
but it does have the albedo texture it
just couldn't load it because the path
was wrong that was stored inside the fbx
file
if that happens you can just select the
actual entity
go to materials you can see that we have
this single material for this entire
model in this case
and then you can just click on albedo
and then navigate to the albedo texture
to load it and then just check use
now it's using it now this looks a
little bit wrong still because
um it's uh like all the other uh like
the metals and the roughness is not
correct
so he's not metal um and he's you could
make him pretty
pretty smooth so he's very reflective by
setting the roughness to zero like this
and now you can see
um he's quite shiny and nice and uh i
think it looks pretty good
obviously if you were doing this
properly you'd probably want to uh
actually
create your own kind of roughness map so
that certain areas like these black
um you know fabrics weren't actually
reflective because they do look like
plastic in this case
so that just the white things were
plastic and maybe not that reflective
maybe not that smooth
um but also the fun thing is you can
just make a metal now you have like kind
of like a chrome
stormtrooper and yeah i think it looks
pretty good
so that is um i guess the latest and
greatest inside hazeldev
we now have animation working more or
less correctly the only thing i haven't
done
here is picking with the mouse so at the
moment you can't pick with the mouse you
actually have to select by the scene
hierarchy um and to be honest i'm not
100 sure how i'm going to solve this
because um obviously sometimes like
these bounding boxes can be quite huge
and to
generate a triangle cache for all of
like for this entire model
um you know with everything else uh
because the animations can be quite long
i'm not sure if that's going to be a
very efficient way of doing things so
we'll see i'm sure i'll come up with
something or maybe i'll just try out the
triangle cache method and see if that's
not too much data to deal with
um but ultimately i guess you would just
need to check the current frame or
something like that but still
transforming all those vertices
maybe in the future when we do it in a
compute shade or other in the
rather than in the vertex shader
everything will be a little bit better
but for now
um that would be a little bit annoying
all right anyway so that is
the animation stuff um also we obviously
don't have any way to actually
control the animations so they just play
and
all of them play as well if you have
like a model that has 10 different
animations in it they will literally all
play
just one after the other um well
depending on how you stole them i guess
so in the future obviously we want to be
able to trigger them we probably want to
just hold the first
frame of some animation that we set up
here maybe trigger them through a script
maybe play them when we actually hit the
play button or something like that
um but at the moment they just all play
which looks pretty cool when you're just
designing a scene like this but
obviously practically if you're making a
game you don't want to just trigger them
all the time
so yeah but baby steps um
that's what we have so far and i do
think that this
is pretty cool
shift that line around
and just for fun here is the same scene
but let's go ahead and change the
skylight
and we will set this to be pink sunrise
which is another
nice kind of scene
let's lower the intensity of the
skylight as well
and maybe the directional light
there we go it looks pretty cool now one
thing i think that's becoming apparent
with all of these things that we're
looking at
is the importance of actually having a
good scene i've said this before but an
engine is obviously only as good as its
assets i could have the best
like code and rendering technology
behind the scenes but if i don't have
good art
it's gonna look like rubbish these are
some pretty nice assets
now if you have some pretty nice assets
maybe some of you watching are actual
3d artists who have like a nice
portfolio of work and you want to donate
some of your assets to hazel so that we
can actually see them maybe use them in
these devlogs
that would be absolutely incredible of
course feel free to get in touch with me
on discord there'll be some details in
the description below i would absolutely
love to see your art and getting into
hazel i think it would be really cool to
build a scene together with art from the
community instead of just my art and
whatever i find online but in general
one of the things that we are working
towards and what i really want to do
when i get the chance
is to actually build a nice beautiful 3d
scene because i think having something
like that
to show off hazel's rendering and maybe
some of the other scripting and
interaction stuff that we have in the
works as well
is going to be really important
obviously so that is that is in fact
the direction that we're heading in so
that is in fact one of our
goals anyway i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please don't
forget to hit the like button
you can help support the development of
hazel by going to patreon.com
you guys will get access to all of this
source code you'll be able to play
around with the scene and actually see
all the code behind it as well as access
to
all of my past backlog of live streams
where i have developed most of
this stuff including a live stream where
we actually jammed these animations in
in the first place and saw what they
looked like
thank you guys for watching i will see
you next time goodbye
you